اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الساعه التي
نكمل فيها تغطيه للهجوم الصاروخيه على
اسرائيل من حيث اطلقت حسب بعض وكالات
الانبياء الاسرائيليه 100 صاروخ من جنوب
لبنان تجاه اسرائيل وفقا لوسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه هيئه المطارات تملك المجال
الجوي في شمال اسرائيل هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه كشفت عن اصابه مستوطنين اثنين
بشظايا صاروخ او صواريخ جراء القصف وزير
الدفاع يجتمع الان مع رئيس الاركان لتقييم
الرد على الهجمات الصاروخيه برد اسرائيلي
ايضا بينت مراسلته العربيه ان قصفا
اسرائيلي وقع على اطراف بلده قلقيليه قرب
مدينه صور في جنوب لبنان مصدر المقرب ايضا
من ميليشيا حزب الله اوضح بالا علاقه
للحزب باطلاق الصواريخ
[موسيقى]
من عنا شايفين شايفين
الكاتب الصحفي مصطفى فحص سيد مصطفى اهلا
وسهلا بك معي ما الذي يحدث الان الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تتطور تداعيات هذه العمليات
واطلاق الصواريخ على اسرائيل من الجنوب
اللبناني
مساء الخير الحادث هو
يدخل في نطاق عسكري كامل اعتدنا في جنوب
لبنان على مدى سنوات انه ان يكون هناك
يكون
الفصائل معينه
باطلاق صاروخ او صاروخين على اكثر على
ابعد تقدير ولكن الان نتحدث ما بين 30 الى
100 صاروخ بمعنى ان هجوم صاروخيه تتعرض له
دوله
اسرائيلي من داخل حدود لبنان اي ان دوله
تهاجم دوله مهما من كان يقف وراء هذه
الهجمات هناك سؤال بالسياسه من لديه
السياده في لبنان لكي يسمح بهذه بان يتحول
لبنان الى منطلقا لعمليات ضد الكيان
الاسرائيلي هل عدنا الى فتره ما قبل 82
ابناء وجود المقاومه الفلسطينيه في جنوب
لبنان وكان جنوب
مباحه للجميع نحن نعلم ان استطاع حزب الله
ضبط الحدود
بطريقه لن تضبطها الدوله اللبنانيه منذ
الاصايل منذ القيام لدوله اسرائيل على
حدودنا والى سنه 2000 عندما كانت هذه
الحدود تقطع لسيطره حزب الله الى هذه
اللحظه كان هناك انضباطا كاملا لا احد
يستطيع الاقتراب او اختراق الحدود
اللبنانيه مع الكيان الاسرائيلي من دون
علم حزب الله اذا ما الذي يحدث الان اين
هي التجاذبات السياسيه التي حصلت
دفعت الى حدوث هذا الامر نحن الجميع يعلم
في لبنان ان الشان الفلسطيني الداخلي
احداث الاقصى الماساويه اليمين الاسرائيلي
المتطرف الذي يذهب الى جنون ما بعده جنود
داخل الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني استزاز المجتمع دوله وحتى
الولايات المتحده هذه الصواريخ هل هي دفاع
عن الاقصى وكل العرب والمسلمين الان في
حاله من التضامن والمحاوله الردع
المستوطنين بالوضع الحكومه وضع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بما تفعله مع الاقصى داخل
القدس المحتله ولكن هل هذه الصواريخ هي
دفاع عن الاقصى ام هناك استفهام كبير خدمه
لنتنياهوك في السياسه هذه الصواريخ تخدم
اليمين الاسرائيلي المتطرق الذي هو يكاد
ان يذهب الى عنف داخلي في اسرائيل نتيجه
للانقسامات الكبيره عندما تاتي هذه
الحادثه في التوقيت الذي يريده الاسرائيلي
لابد من القول ان هناك شبهات كما ايضا من
الجانب اللبناني السلطه اللبنانيه وهو
الامر الواقع في الجنوب لبنان لا تستطيع
ان ترفع يدها وتقول لا نعلم من وفجاه
تتحرك فصائل فلسطينيه الفلسطينيين غير
مباح لهم العوده الى احداث ما قبل 82 لان
هناك اجماع لبناني حتى من بيئه المقاومه
حتى من يؤكد يريد تحرير فلسطين عبر لبنان
ان لا يستطيع احد تجاوز هذه الحدود من
قرار من دون قرار وطني لبناني او قرار
مقاوم لبناني في الجانب الاخر اذا من سمح
بهذا الشكل
يعني اذا كانت هذه المناطق اولا هل هي
خارجه عن سيطره حزب الله مناطق الجنوب في
الحدود اللبناني هل نتوقع او هل يمكن ان
نتخيل ان مثل هذا العدد من الصواريخ يطلق
من هذه المناطق الى دوله الى اسرائيل دون
ضوء اخضر او حتى معرفه او علم من قبل حزب
الله التي تسيطر على الكثير من المناطق في
هذه في في المناطق الحدود اللبنانيه
جنوب لبنان تقول لا يمكن ان تمر يمر طير
فوق جنوب لبنان من دون علم القوه التي
تسيطر امنيا على جنوب لبنان لذلك هذا
التجاذب السياسي في خدمه من من يريد
استيعال هذه الازمه
من خلال الحدود اللبنانيه الفلسطينيه ولو
العلم ان هناك مفتوحه في سوريا هناك يوميا
نشاط للعدو الاسرائيلي ضد اهداف لحزب الله
وللايرانيين في سوريا لم يتم الرد لماذا
لم تستخدم جبهه الجولان للتخفيف عن الاقصى
واهل واهل القدس لماذا يستخدم جنوب لبنان
في هذه اللحظه هل هناك قرار في فتح مناوشه
سياسيه او احتكاكات خشنه في ظروف سياسيه
معقده هذا التجارب
السياسي في المنطقه في الداخل اللبناني
وفي الداخل الاسرائيلي قد يؤدي الى نوع من
العنف الذي لا نعرف لا نعرف حدوده وخصوص
وايضا هناك سؤال اخر او هناك تساؤل اخر
اذا قال حزب الله والدوله اللبنانيه ان
ليس لدينا اي علاقه او معرفه بهذه
الصواريخ لنفترض في المكتب قبل اسرائيلي
او حتى الان هناك مصادر من حزب الله تحدثت
عن ذلك نعم في المقابل الاسرائيلي سيرون
سيرد داخل لبنان اذا هذا انتهاك السياده
اللبنانيه هل سترد الدوله اللبنانيه
وفصائل المقاومه اللبنانيه على الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه هناك القضيه ليست صاروخ او
صاروخين القضيه
دفعه اول شيء اللبنانيين لن يسمحوا
للفلسطينيين باستخدام اراضيهم بهذه
الطريقه من اجل قضيه وايضا السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ايضا اجماع فلسطين على تحيه كل
الطوق الفلسطيني من هذه من الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي اذا من يفتعل هذه
هذه الازمه الان حسب ما نشاهد في الاخبار
العاجله من صحيفه معاريف الاسرائيليه تقول
ان التقييم الاولي الاسرائيلي لهذه
العمليات ان من وراءها هي حماس في لبنان
وحسب مراسله العربيه هناك طائرات استطلاع
اسرائيليه الان تحلق في جنوب لبنان هل
يمكن هل يمكن ان يتخلى الان اذا كان الامر
بهذا الشكل اذا ذهب هذا التقييم
الاسرائيلي لان هناك فصائل فلسطينيه او
حماس في لبنان هي المسؤوله عن هذه العمليه
هل يمكن ان نتوقع حجم الرد
الاسرائيلي كيف سيكون يعني هل سيكون
على مصادر النيران المتواجده في هذه
المنطقه واذا كان الامر بذلك هل سيتم
التعرض للجبهه الجنوبيه لحزب الله في هذا
الاطار ام ماذا يعني كيف يمكن توقع الرد
يعني نستطيع القول ان نتنياهو لديه عدوى
بعثيه لان سيرد دائما في الزمان والمكان
المناسبين
وتحديدا ما يصدر حتى الان من القياده
العسكريه الاسرائيليه هو يتجنب استيعال
فتح الجبهات بان الخيار سيكون ردا على على
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لان حتى الوضع الداخلي
في اسرائيل انقسام القوى المؤسسه السياسيه
والمؤسسه الاسرائيلي المؤسسه الاسرائيليه
السياسيه والعسكريه داخل الاسره داخل
اسرائيل
يبعد حتى هذه اللحظه تقديرا يبعد شبح
الحرب الموسعه لن اقول حرب شامله الحرب
الموسعه لذلك
ستتدرع المؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
المعنيه بالرد بعيدا عن الموقف المؤسسه
السياسيه بان من قام بهذا الفعل هو فصائل
الفلسطينيه لذلك الرد سيكون على الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في لبنان يقص هل هذا خلق
سيعتبره لبنان خرق للسياده ام ان النظام
التخادم الغير معلن بين القوه المتصارعه
في هذه المنطقه بان هناك
بان هناك تحديد
اللي قام بالهجوم وسيحدد كيفيه الرد اذا
كانت القوى الاسرائيليه
وهذا للداخل الاسرائيلي غير قادره الان
على وقف التجاذبات الداخليه
والتوحد توحيد الجبهه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه ضد لبنان
فهاذا لم يحدث فانا سيكون الرد مجتزا محدد
ضمن الاراضي اللبنانيه اختراق السياده
ولكن ضد الفصائل الفلسطيني ماذا عن موقف
حزب الله يعني انت تقول قبل قليل بانه لا
يمكن ان نتوقع ان يطير طير في هذه المناطق
دون ان تعرف الجهات التي تسيطر عليها يعني
بالتالي هنا نتحدث تحديدا عن حزب ما مصلحه
حزب الله في هذا التوقيت
ان يطلق مثل او يقبل او يرضى او يعطي ضوء
اخضر لهذه الفصائل ان تطلق الصواريخ على
اسرائيل
اعتقد منذ اتفاق الترسيم وبعد تزايد
الهجمات الاسرائيليه على مواقع حزب الله
والحرس الثوري في سوريا والتي اصبحت محرجه
لايران داخليا بعدم بعدم الرد مطلقا على
هذه لا حزب الله بحاجه الى
قبض الطرف او من نسميه بالعاميه تنفيسه
بانه يسمح من اجل احتواء الداخل الذي
بداخل البيئه البيئه الحاضره او بيئه
المقاومه بان حزب الله لا يقف مكتوب في
الايدي امام هذه الاعاده وان الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه التي كانت تريد ان
اسرائيل خلال سبع دقائق ونصف وهي الان
يوميا تتعرض لضربات بداخل ايران وليس فقط
في سوريا ولم تقوم باي ايراد هذه حاله من
اجل تخفيف
بالاجل نص السقوط الداخليه لهذا المحور
لذلك حزب الله نوعا ما يستفيد منها ومن
قراءتها الخاصه للواقعه الاسرائيلي
الداخلي الواقع نتنياه الواقع المؤسسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه والعسكريه بان مهما
جرى من الرد لن يكون الرد موسعا خصوصا اذا
اتفق الطرفان الاسرائيلي واللبناني ان
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تتحمل مسؤوليه الحادث
شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب الصحفي مصطفى فحص
كنت معي من بيروت
اذهب الى ايضا مراسل مدير مكتب العربيه في
القدس زياد حلبي زياد ضعنا في اخر
التطورات
الاحصائيه الاسرائيليه لاطلاق الصواريخ هي
خمسه اطلاق 25
صاروخا من جنوب لبنان تجاه منطقه الجليل
معظم هذه الصواريخ هي من نوع كاتيوشا
واغراد صواريخ قديما نسبيا اطلقت على
دفعات
عمليا خمسه منها سقطت في اطار المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه الباقيه ساقطت في مناطق
مفتوحه وفي البحر بعد الصواريخ سقطت ايضا
المعلومات الاخيره الراشحه هي ان نتنياهو
سيعقد اجتماعا للحكومه الامنيه المصغره
هذا المساء لتحديد ربما الرد الاسرائيلي
على ما يحدث التسريبات الاسرائيليه
المتواتره تتهم الفصائل الفلسطينيه بل
وتسميها تسميها عمليا في لبنان تقول ان
حماس في لبنان هي من اطلقت هذه الصواريخ
هذا ربما يقود الى الاعتقاد بان ثمه ردا
اسرائيليا قابلا للاحتواء بدون كسر قواعد
اللعبه قد نشد للرد في منطقتين في قطاع
غزه لان الان الاتهام يوجه لحماس وفي
لبنان لان الصواريخ اطلقت من لبنان قد
يكون اطلاق قذائف مدفعيه سؤال كان هناك
تخطيط لما هو اكبر لغارات من المقاتلات او
شيء من هذا القبيل لان هذا عمليا يغير
قواعد اللعبه في الاشتباك عمليا بشكل او
باخر من اي المناطق تحديدا تم ارسال هذه
الصواريخ واطلاق وهل تنفي الان تماما
عدد المائه صاروخ كانت البعض صاروخ التي
تحدثت عنه بعض وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيلي
يبدو ان هناك من كان يعد صواريخ
كيف فقط نقرب للمشاهد لا يحدث عاده عندما
ياتي صاروخ في الاجواء تجاه الاراضي
الاسرائيليه يتم اعتراضه على الاقل
بصاروخين اثنين من بطاريه القبه الحديديه
فاذا كان الحديث عن 25 صاروخا حوالي 50
صاروخا جرى اطلاقها عمليا من بطاريات
القبه الحديديه فعل الانذار 37 مره في
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه هذا خلق البلبل
ربما في الاحصاء الاولي 100 صاروخ خمسين
او خمسين صاروخ وما الى ذلك من هذه
الاحصائيات حاليا العدد شبه النهائي هو
بانه اطلق اطلق اطلق عفوا 25 صاروخا من
جنوب لبنان تجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
كان هناك اصابه يعني منشئه
تزويد الوقود في احدى المستوط اصابه طفيفه
ايضا لاسرائيلي من جراء سقوط
شظيه من صاروخ بالقرب منه عمليا فقط من
يتواجد في المستوطنات الحدوديه طلب منه
البقاء بالقرب من مكان امن لكن علينا ان
نشير ايضا الى ان التوقيت اطلاق الصواريخ
وتوقيت بحد ذاته لافت لان عمليا معظم
الاسرائيليين يتواجدون اليوم في اجازه في
اجازه عيد الفصح اول ايام عيد الفصح
اليهودي يتواجدون بشكل كبير جدا في
المستوطنات الشماليه الحدوديه
وبالتالي هذا قد يلعب دورا ايضا في حجم
الرد الاسرائيلي وان كان الحديث المتواتر
عن اتهام حماس تنظيف فلسطيني هذا وكانه
يقال بين السطور سنرد ولكن بما يكون قابلا
للاحتواء بدون كسر قواعد اللعبه ولكن هل
تعلم اين ترد اسرائيل على هذه الفصائل هل
هناك مناطق محدده لتواج دهما من القصف
ربما والرد قد يكون عشوائي على بعض
المناطق في الحدود الجنوبيه
بعض المناطق المفتوحه غير الاهل عاده
بالسكان يعني
لن ترى اسرائيل تقصف قرى لبنانيه بشكل
مباشر لان ذلك سيقود الى حرب قد يكون
عمليه قصف للمنطقه التي يفترض ان الصواريخ
اطلقت منها اطلقت من ثلاث مناطق عمليا
الصواريخ في جنوب لبنان قد تطلق الى تلك
المناطق المفتوحه التي انطلقت منها
الصواريخ قذائف مدفعيه السؤال هل تقوم
اسرائيل بغارات محدوده في المقاتلات لانها
عمليا خالد علينا ان نشير الى هذا الامر
اسرائيل تتجنب بشكل كامل تقريبا يعني
نادرا ما تقوم بغارات جويه لان ذلك يقود
الى الرد بالصواريخ من قبل حزب الله هي لا
تدخل في هذا الموضوع ترد عاده على
الصواريخ الفلسطينيه باطلاق قذائف مدفعيه
لكن هنا المتغير ربما هو الحجم حجم هذا
هذه الصواريخ او الكميه عفوا نتحدث عن
عشرات الصواريخ هذا قد يستدعي ردا مغيره
قليلا في الداخل الاسرائيلي كيف تم
التعامل مع هذه الخلايا ايضا زياد مساله
اطلاق الصواريخ هل هناك متغير تم رصدها
مشاهدته
طبعا هذا الامر
وجد الاسرائيليين في خضم اجازه عيد الفصح
وهذه الاجازه يتجولون فيها في كل مكان
لهذا كانت حلقه
سريعه جدا
لاستدراك الموقف المقاتلات كانت في
الاجواء في الدقائق الاولى لاطلاق
الصواريخ ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي او
عزالي رئيس هيئه الاركان بان يحضر ردا
اوليا الرد الذي نتحدث عنه عاده بالقصف
المدفعي ريثما تجتمع الحكومه الامنيه
المصغره لاول مره منذ ثلاثه اشهر يجمع
نتنياهو هذه الحكومه بعد ان كان غارقا في
الازمه الداخليه
وبالتالي هذا الامر سيتم هذه الليله قد
تطهضح الامور اكثر لجهه طبيعه الرد
الاسرائيلي لكن الاعتقاد بانه لم يكن
مفاجئا ان تاتي صواريخ من جنوب لبنان
السبب في ذلك يعني يمكن التحدث عن ام
اثنين في هذا الموضوع الاول هو عاده عندما
تكون هناك اعتداءات على الاقصى وتفعل
الجبهات التي باتت بوحده في السنوات
الاخيره اقصد صواريخ من قطاع غزه توتر في
القدس وداخل الخط الاخضر والضفه الغربيه
عاده تطلق صواريخ رمزيه من جنوب لبنان في
مثل هذه الحالات ثلاث مرات تكرر هذا
الموضوع في السابق وهذا ليس جديدا لكن
القراءه الاسرائيليه الاخرى بان حزب الله
حاول التحقيق عمليا ان يضرب عصفورين يصيب
عصفورين بحجر واحد اولا
الظهور بانه يعطي ضوء اخضر للفصائل
الفلسطينيه لمسانده ما يحدث داخل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه الامر الاخر في اطار المواجهه
الاقليميه مع اسرائيل قد يكون هذا عن طريق
هذه الفصائل جزءا من رد على المواجهه
الاسرائيليه التي تجري في الاراضي السوريه
اساسا
يعني من يقول بان هذه الصواريخ لا يمكن ان
تطلق ابدا من هذه المنطقه الا بعلم حزب
الله او بضوء اخضر من مثل هذا الكلام كيف
يمكن يمكن النظر اليه في اسرائيل في هذا
التوقيت يعني وخاصه من قبل
الجهات ذات العلاقه
بالجيش الاسرائيلي يعني زياد
في اسرائيل دائما يتهمون حزب الله بان ذلك
ما تقوله عمليا صحيح بانه لا يمكن اطلاق
هذا الكم من الصواريخ بدون ان يعي ان يعرف
حزب الله ذلك او ان يعني يوحي بانه موافق
على ذلك للفصائل الفلسطينيه لكن بغض النظر
عمليا كما يحدث مع حماس في قطاع غزه في
بعض الاحيان فصائل الفلسطينيه تطلق
الصواريخ لكن اسرائيل ترد على اهداف تابعه
لحماس عادد عاده في هذه الحال يبدو
الاصرار الاسرائيلي على اتهام حماس في
جنوب لبنان بانه يفتح الطريق امام امرين
ان ترد اسرائيل هذه الليله على قطاع غزه
لنستبعد ذلك ابدا لانها تتهم حماس من
لبنان وانت ترد على لبنان بشكل محدود
نسبيا لان صواريخ انطلقت في نهايه الامر
من الاراضي اللبنانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من القدس مدير مكتب العربيه
زياد حلبي
ايضا ينضم الينا من القدس يوني بالمناخيم
المحلل السياسي السيد
يوني ما هو التقييم الاسرائيلي برايك الان
لهذه العمليه في هذه التوقيت
هذا الهجوم كان متوقعا من قبل الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه
وهذا حصل في الماضي هذا ليس اول مره
بان في هناك الصواريخ من الاراضي
اللبنانيه باتجاه اسرائيل هذا الامر بدا
في عمليه سيف القدس قبل سنتين
واسرائيل
في هذا الوقت
ردت بكسف بيدفع باتجاه
الاراضي العمرانيه اسرائيل تحمل
رسميا تحمل الحكومه اللبنانيه
بما حصل لانها هي صاحبه السياده في لبنان
وستقدم اسرائيل الشكوى الى مجلس الامن
للامم المتحده ولكن ايضا
[موسيقى]
هو
لحزب الله بغض النظر انه عناصر حماس هم
الذين اطلقوا الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل
ولكن كل طفل في لبنان يعلم بان ليس هناك
امكانيه
لاطلاق عيسى روح من جنوب لبنان بدون اذن
من حزب الله
والمعلومات الاستخباراتيه الموجوده لدى
اسرائيل هي بانه كانوا هناك تنسيق
بين حصن الصغار وبين
صالح العروي من حماس
تنسيق مسبق وكان هناك ضوء افضل من
من حزب الله لحماس بيتلاك هذه الصواريخ
باتجاه الصين
الرد الاسرائيلي
لم اسمع سؤال كيف سيكون رد اسرائيل على
هذه العمليه وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
تحدث يقول سنتخذ جميع الاجراءات لحمايه
امننا نعم
اذا استمر قصف السواحي من لبنان اذا استمر
انا اعتقد بان سيكون هناك عسكري في
الاراضي اللبنانيه نفسها ولكن اذا لم توقف
حسب المعلومات التي تاتينا توقف في القصف
فبالتالي
اسرائيل بهذه التصريحات ام سترد على ما
اطلق يعني
الم
فيكون هناك اجتماع للمجلس الامني المصرغ
برئاسه رئيس الوزراء وانا اعتقد انا اذا
هو الحدث الوحيد الذي
سيحدث اليوم من
الاراضي اللبنانيه اسرائيل ستحتوي
الموقف كما عملت في السابق ويكون هناك
مدفعي باتجاه المناطق المفتوحه في لبنان
كما حصل في الماضي
والغد الاسرائيلي الحقيقي باتجاه حماس
وحزب الله الغد العسكري الاسرائيلي سيكون
في قطاع غزه او في الاراضي السوريه
وهناك اهداف كثيره لحزب الله داخل سوريا
واسرائيل
قصفت بالماضي وستكصف ايضا بالمستقبل هذه
الهدف
نتابع معكم الان هذه الصور من الاضرار
التي وقعت على بعض المستوطنات في شمال
اسرائيل جراء القصف قصف الصواريخ من لبنان
كان جيش الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في عقاب
التقرير بشان انطلاق سفارات الانذار في
بعض البلدات مثل شلومي موشاف وبتزيد
انه تم اطلاق صواريخ من لبنان باتجاه
الاراضي الاسرائيليه تم اعتراض احدها في
البدايه كان ذلك التصريح من الجيش
الاسرائيلي وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الان
وحسب الاخبار العاجله يقول بان ستتخذ جميع
الاجراءات الكفيله بحمايه امنيه
مراسل العربيه ايضا تحدث عن ان التقييم
الاسرائيلي الاخير كان قد وضع عدد 30
صاروخ ربما اطلقت من الجنوب اللبناني
الهيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون الاسرائيليه
قالت ان التقييم الامني الاول يحمل او
يتحدث عنه 25 صاروخ انطلقت من جنوب لبنان
بحسب مراسل العربيه من الجنوب اللبناني
باتجاه اسرائيل
وايضا كانت تقييم الاولي الامني ربما يحمل
حماس في لبنان مسؤوليات اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ السيد يوني اذا الرد اذا ما تم
الرد الاسرائيلي عندما تم سيكون رد محدود
على شكل اطلاق قذائف
مدفعيه
سيكون قصف مدفعي باتجاه المناطق المفتوحه
التي تم
منها اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل ليس
هناك اي نيه لقصف القوى اللبنانيه
ولكن هدس هذه ستكون خطوه اوليه الغاز
الحقيقي العسكري
سيكون
الهداف حماس استطاع غزه وعلى الاهداف في
الحزب الله في سوريا
وماذا عن لبنان لن يتم الرد على حزب الله
في لبنان
كما قلت اذا توقف هذا الكشف السواحي يصلك
تريد الانشغال وفتح جبهه جديده مع لبنان
مع حزب الله في لبنان ودحولي لمعركه
مع حزب الله هي لا ذلك ولكن اذا استمر
القصف السموحي من لبنان انا اعتقد انا
سيكون هناك
غادي اسرائيلي على اهداف حماس في جنوب
لبنان ما هي غايه حزب الله من من السماح
باطلاق الصواريخ في هذا التوقيت حسب
تقييمك سيد مناحي
هذا اسرائيل كانت تحذر في الاسابيع
الاخيره بان
محور المقاومه
برئاسه ايران هو الذي
[موسيقى]
هات الدوري الاخضر لحزب الله ولا الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
بفتح جميل جبهات
للمواجهه مع اسرائيل
وراينا قبل شهر تقريبا
الهجوم في مفترق مجيده في شمال اسرائيل
التي نفذ لايدي احد عناصر حزب الله
ولذلك هذا كان متوقع انه خلال شهر رمضان
المبارك ستكون هناك استفزازات من حزب الله
ومن حماس في محاوله اسرائيل الى معركه في
جميل جبهات
انا اعتقد بان هذا التقييم خاطي لحزب الله
ولا ايران ولا كل من يفكر بان اسرائيل
ضعيفه وذلك بسبب الموجه الاحتجاجات
الداخليه في اسرائيل
والعلاقات المتوتره بين
نتنياهو والرئيس الامريكي بايدن هذا تقييم
خاطي لانه الجيش الاسرائيلي هو قائم قوي
جدا
وفي حاله الطوارئ
في هناك
وحده وطنيه اسرائيليه
بغض النظر عن الخلافات الداخليه والازمه
الداخليه
هذا هو موقف الشعب الاسرائيلي
ولذلك انا اتوقع اذا استمر العدوان لحزب
الله
تكون هناك ضربه قويه اسرائيليه وفي هناك
المزيد من الاهداف لحزب الله ولا ايران
في ايران نفسها وفي الاراضي السوريه
ولذلك كما قلت تقييم حزب له تقييم خاطئ
طيب نتابع معكم ايضا هذه الصور المباشره
من احدى المستوطنات في اسرائيل
مستوطنات حيث الان ربما عمليه تمشيطه امني
لهذه المنطقه التي
نشاهد بعض ربما بقايا صاروخ قد وصل اليها
حسب المشاهد هذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت من
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه اعود اليك
السيد مناحيم هذا الموقف لن يؤثر على
بنيامين نتنياهو على حكومته التي تعاني
كثيرا داخليا
صحيح وهي تعاني
[موسيقى]
هي جاهزه لمواجهه اي اعتداء او اي عدوان
من قبل ايران او حزب الله شكرا جزيلا لك
يعني بالمناخيم المحلل السياسي من القدس
شكرا لك من بيروت ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي حنا صالح سيد حنا مرحبا بك من
المعني اليوم بجر المنطقه الى حرب يعني
بعد هذه العمليه في الجنوب اللبناني او في
باطلاق صواريخ على اسرائيل من لبنان
بدايه لابد من القول ان ما جرى استعراض
دموي قد يجر ويلات على لبنان ولا يؤمن
الدعم للشعب الفلسطيني ولا لقضيه الاقصى
بل يمنح مزيد من الاوراق لنتنياهو الذي
يواجه ازمات داخليه في اسرائيل ومع
الفلسطينيين في الداخل
اظن ان الموضوع يجب ان يعالج او ينظر له
سياسيا
استخدام جنوب لبنان هل حزب الله المتوجس
من الاتفاق السعودي الايراني بشراكه الصين
والاتفاق الذي اقلق اسرائيل وكان هناك
تحفظات من بعض الازرع
الايرانيه في المنطقه في العراق مثلا
هل يفسر هذا التحفظ هذه الخطوه التي جرت
هل هناك
حزب الله مثلا سيقبل باطلاق صواريخ
احتجاجا على الاتفاق السعودي الايراني دون
معرفه ايران او دون علم ايران
اريد ان اوضح انه قد يكون هناك لدى الازرع
الايرانيه في المنطقه وربما جهات في الحرس
الثوري تحفظات قد تدفع هذه الوجهه لا يمكن
اطلاق الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان الا بمعرفه
حزب الله يستحيل غير ذلك وبمعرفه ذلك
بالضبط هذا قرار ليس محليا هو قرار ابعد
من
الوضع اللبناني ليس موضوع صراع بين غزه
واسرائيل
اكثر تعقيدا كل الغارات كل الضربات التي
قامت بها
الجيش الاسرائيلي ضد المواقع الحرس الثوري
وحزب الله في سوريا لم تلقى
اذا ربطناه بما قلت بانه بالتوجس من
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني سيدحنا انا انا
اريد ان انا اريد ان اقول ربما هناك جهات
تتحفظ على هذا الاتفاق وتسعى لبعض الخربطه
حزب الله لا يتحمل بالعلم المسؤوليه
الكامله ان جهه فلسطينيه قامت باطلاق
الصواريخ كما يقال حزب الله لم يصدر بيان
رسمي ولكن عمليا عندما يتم توزيع معلومات
عن مصدر مقرب من حزب الله هذا الله ان لا
علاقه وجهه النظر الاخرى او
الذي كنت تريد ان تصل الى ربما اذا علمت
ايران وحزب الله واعطى الضوء الاخضر لهذه
الفصائل او لحزب الله باطلاق هذه الصواريخ
والسؤال في هذا التوقيت ما هي مصلحه ايران
ما هي مصلحه حزب الله من عمليه بهذا النوع
في هذا التوقيت في هذا الظرف
هل هناك جهاد بايران تريد فصل المسارات
وعدم معالجه الملفات العالقه في المنطقه
كلها ارتباطا بهذا الاتفاق هل تريد بعض
الجهات حصر الموضوع بالمساله اليمنيه وعدم
التطرق للوضع في لبنان وسوريا والعراق
الاسئله كثيره لكن الامر الثابت لا يمكن
لحماس ان تقدم على هذه الخطوه اذا صح ان
حماس هي وحدها او هي الجهه التي اطلقت
الصواريخ 25 لا يمكن ان تبدن على هذه
الخطوه بدون ضوء اخضر من حزب الله ولا
يمكن لعمليه من هذا النوع ان يبضم عليها
حزب الله دون توافقات مع قياده الفيلاق
القدس مع الحرس الثوري مع جهه ايرانيه
معينه حزب الله بالنهايه هو جزء من هذه
القوى هو جزء اساسي واجهه اساسيه
في المنطقه هل هناك جهات في ايران متضرره
تريد ان تعرقل
ربما
الساعات والايام الاتيه تقدم اجوبه باي
حال كان للمرشد حديث انه سيمنع الاعتراض
على الاتفاق عندما يكون هناك حديث على هذا
المستوى في ايران يعني ان هناك جهات
متوتره من الاتفاق خصوصا وان صياغه كل
الاتفاق تتم مع جهات ليست مقربه من الحرس
الثوري لماذا لم نقول ان المساله وداني
هنا فقط اشير الاخبار العاجله مراسل
العربيه اتحدث من اقل بان معظم الصواريخ
التي تم اطلاقها باتجاه اسرائيل كانت من
طرف
والقناه الاسرائيليه 12 نقلا عن مصادر
امنيه قالوا لن ندخل في حرب مع حزب الله
لكن سنرد
الرد اين سيكون هل هو في هذا الاطار
المحدود الذي تحدث عنه قبل قليل السيد
مناحيم
مدفعيه ستكون على مناطق مفتوحه على الحدود
اذا كان الامر بهذا الشكل هل حصلت او حصل
حزب الله وايران على ما تريد من هذا
الاختبار في هذا التوقيت في هذا الاطلاق
طيله المرحله الماضيه وقد حدث عده مرات
اطلاق صواريخ كان الرد الاسرائيلي يكون
على مناطق مفتوحه لم يتم استهداف اي بلده
ولم يستلم استهداف مواقع بل قيل ان القصف
المدفعي
حاول ان يضرب المناطق التي اطلقت منها
الصواريخ حتى الان قد يكون حدود الرد هذا
هو المستوى الممكن مع التركيز في تل ابيب
كما بيانات المقربين من حزب الله ان لا
علاقه لحزب الله بشكل مباشر انه ليس حزب
الله هو الذي اطلق هذه الصواريخ لكن
الموضوع ربما يحمل اكثر من رساله ابقاء
لبنان صندوق بريد انه بالامكان فتح جبهه
جديده
بالامكان العوده لممارسه الضغط مع العلم
ان لبنان وقع معاهده الترسيم
والطرف الذي وقع المعاهده او فرض توقيع
المهاره المعاهده هو حزب الله وايران
لانها تضمنت التنازلات كبرى مقابل اسنان
من حقوق لبنان مقابل اسناننا لايران بينها
زياده ضخ النفط الايراني الى اخره
صالح ساعود اليك في اطار هذه التغطيه
ساذهب الى بيروت يعني مراسله العربيه غنوه
يتيم غنوه مرحبا بك دعينا في اخر التطورات
غنوه هل تسمعين
غنوه طيب لم اتمكن من سماع السؤال الان
تسمعيني جيدا
غنوه
نعم ساتحدث عن المعلومات الجديده التي
وردت قبل قليل هو بيان اليونسفيل الذي صدر
قبل قليل تحدث عن ان الاوضاع الجديه اليوم
في جنوب لبنان وطالب من جميع الاطراف
اتخاذ الاجراءات الذي
للبقاء على على حضرها تحدث عن ان هناك
مشاورات بين الجانبين اللبناني
والاسرائيلي عند عند الخط الازرق وكانت
ايضا قوات اليونيفل كاتدبير احترازي قد
طلبت من موظفيها التوجه الى الملاج ولكن
هذا لا يعني بان هناك خطوره هذا فقط تدبير
احترازي تتخذه في كل مره ايضا كان هناك
بيان قد صدر رئيس حزب القوات سمير جعجع
تساءل فيه عن دور الحكومه يعني
بعمليه ضبط الحدود وما هي مصلحه لبنان من
اطلاق هذا الكم من الصواريخ اليوم وسال
ايضا ان كان هناك زج في جنوب لبنان فهل
هناك امكانيه لاصلاحه يتحدث بالطبعا
الازمه الاقتصاديه غير ذلك لم يصدر اي
تصريح رسمي ولم
يتمنى اي جهه حتى الان اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
علما ان اسمع الهنيه كان في زياره الى
بيروت وصلها يوم امس وكان ايضا هناك
اجتماع مع امين عم حزب الله اليوم حسن نصر
الله البعض يعني كان هناك اقارن بين
اللقاء الذي جمعهما وبين الصواريخ التي
اطلقت من جنوب لبنان المنطقه التي اطلقت
منها الصواريخ بالطبع الجيش اللبناني كان
قد نفذ انتشار فيها ولكن حتى الان لم يصدر
اي بيان رسمي عن ايجاد منصه اطلاق اطلاق
الصواريخ
اهالي الجنوب تحدثوا عن ان هناك
عشرات الصواريخ التي اطلقت والتي تمكنوا
من سماع صدى اطلاق صدى اطلاق صوتها
كان هناك طائرات استطلاع اسرائيليه فوق
كره جرويه بعد اطلاق الصواريخ كان هناك
لغط حول موضوع الرد المدفعي الاسرائيلي
وهو ما نفاه الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكن يبدو
ان القبه الحديديه عندما تعترض صواريخ
تسقط هذه الصواريخ ربما فيما اماكن مفتوحه
في لبنان هذا الامر فسره بعض بانه رد
اسرائيلي ولكنه لم يكن هناك اي رد
اسرائيلي حتى الان يبدو ان عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ توقفت توقفت الان كان هناك
بحسب بعض المعلومات دفعتين من الصواريخ
التي اطلقت ولكن كما ذكرت اي بيان رسمي
للجيش اللبناني لم يصدر حتى هذه اللحظه
لكن هل يتوقع ان يتحرك الجيش اللبناني على
صعيد تفتيش ربما المنطقه للبحث عن مطلق
هذا هذه الصواريخ هل يمكن ان يحدث ذلك
مكثفه بعد اطلاق بعد اطلاق الصواريخ ايضا
سيكون هناك ربما يعني بعض
يعني
التسيير السيارات
بالاشتراك مع مع اليونيفال ولكن لم يحدث
ان سبق وتم القاء القبض على مطلقيه
الصواريخ بعد بعض الاحيان كانت تبقى هذه
الصواريخ تطلق بدون ان تتحمل اي جهه
مسؤوليه اطلاقها ولكن
بحسب معلومات الجيش تكون فصائل ومجموعات
فلسطينيه ولكن ايضا هذه المجموعات كون
المنطقه تقع تحت سيطره حزب الله لا يمكن
ان تتحرك
براحه تامه من دون ان يكون هناك طرف من
قبل حزب الله شكرا جزيلا لك غنويم من
بيروت مراسله العربيه
عود الى ضيفي من بيروت ايضا الكاتب الصحفي
حنان صالح
ماذا بعد هذه العمليه سيد حنا يعني على
الوضع في المعادله المعادله الامنيه
الموجوده على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه هل هذه العمليه اي التاثير في
مساله ربما
استعدادات كل طرف لما يقال بانها حرب ستقع
ستقع بين اسرائيل وحزب الله
شئنا ما بين كما يذهب الكثير الى الى هذا
التقييم او التحليل
اظن انه بهذه الحدود يمكن ان تكون
حفاظ على المستوى السابق من المواجهه بين
مزدوجين المواجهه بين اسرائيل وحزب الله
ونحن لم نشهد اي مواجهه منذ حرب 2006
الحدود امنه المناطق امنه ما زرع كان
اعمال جد بسيطه هل هناك اتجاه لخلق هذا
الوضع
مع كل هذه الانهيارات والمجاعه التي تحاصر
اللبنانيين لا اظن ان حزب الله في وضع
يمكنه من الذهاب الى حرب
مفتوحه مع اسرائيل تقديري الموضوع يتطلب
وضع اخر وجهوزيه اخرى رغم كل الانتشار
لحزب الله العسكري الموجود في سوريا مع
الحرس الثوري لم يتم اي رد وهناك امكانيه
للرد من الجولان واضح في لبنان اضعف
عسكريا مما هو في سوريا هذه حقيقه صحيح
حزب الله
منتشر وموجود في مناطق جنوبيه لكن هناك
ايضا مناطق جنوبيه بفضل اليونسل مقفله
ليست كل المناطق مفتوحه
كجبهه واسعه هناك شبه مقفله اكثر من منطقه
وهناك تحفظات واسعه من جانب الاهالي على
اي عمل عسكري نذكر قبل فتره في منطقه شويه
عندما صدر الاهالي رجب الحزب الله علنا
وعلى الكاميرات وامام كل يعني
ما من بيئه قابله لفتح الحرب هذه عناصر
يجب اخذها بعين الاعتبار باي حال الوضع
الراهن هو خساره كامله للالبان وعدم ربح
للفلسطينيين هناك ربح لاسرائيل هل تجنيد
ايران من هذه العمليه انها وجهت رساله
اعادت لبنان كما تريده دائما صندوق بريد
لتوجيه رسائل انها قادره على فتح جبهات
مقابل هذا التصعيد تريد اثمان ما في مكان
ما
اظن التطورات اللاحقه ممكن ان تعطي
الاجوبه لكن لكن ان لم يكن ايران كقياده
لابد ان تكون جهات ايرانيه هي التي شجعت
على هذه الخطوه شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب
الصحفي حني صالح حنا صالح من بيروت
من القدس ينضم الى الدكتور ماهر المصري
واستاد العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
العبريه دكتور مايل مرحبا بك ماذا سيفعل
نتنياهو الان للرد على ما حدث
ي كريم قبل ان ندخل في سوق الموضوع انا
اريد هنا ان اذكر بانه الحديث هنا عن
اراضي اسرائيليه اراضي جزء من دوله
اسرائيل وليست اراضي محتله او اراضي
متنازع عليها الاراضي التي اطلقت عليها
الصواريخ وبالتالي بلداتنا في الشمال ليست
مستوطنات الاسرائيليين الذين تعرضوا لهذا
القصر ليسوا مستوطنين فانا يعني لدي رجاء
لقناه العربيه والسيد زياد حلبي يعني ان
يكفوا عن استخدام كلمه مستوطن ومستوطنين
يعني هذه مفردات محور ايران وبالتالي
الرجاء هذه بلدات قرى والمناسبه الكثير من
هذه
البلدات وكذلك مستوطنين لن ندخل في صلب
الموضوع طبعا
نتنياهو هو استاذي الكريم اسرائيل دوله
هناك اجهزه امنيه هذه الاجهزه تعمل بحرفيه
وبمهنيه يعني ربما كان متوقع ان تطلق هذه
تطلق صواريخ من جهات داخل من الداخل
اللبناني طبعا بمباركه حزب الله انا لا
اتصور يتصور احد في اسرائيل انه بامكان
مجموعه مسلحه ان تطلق صواريخ على ربما ليس
بعلم الدوله اللبنانيه صحيح لان الدوله
غائبه تماما عن المشهد ولنتساءل هنا اين
هو رئيس الوزراء واين الحكومه ولكن ليس
بغياب ايران وايران في لبنان هو حزب الله
لا شك في ذلك هناك بنيه هرميه وانا لا
اتصور انا صاروخا واحدا من الممكن ان يطلق
من الاراضي اللبنانيه بدون علم وبدون ان
تكون هناك موافقه من القياده الايرانيه
عبر طبعا حزب الله بطبيعه الحال انا اعتقد
انه سوف يكون هناك ردا محدودا حتى هذه
اللحظه حيث توقفت توقفت الضربات ولكن في
نهايه المطاف الحديث هنا عن جريمه حرب لو
لم تكن منظومه القبه الحديديه لقتل مئات
الاسرائيليين اسرى هذه الضربات الهدف من
هذه من هذه ضربات الصاروخيه هو قتل قتل
المدنيين قتل البشر وبالتالي يجب ان تكون
هناك انا اعتقد الحكومه سوف ترد وترد بشكل
حازم وقاطع ولكن
جيد دكتور ماهر كيف سترد بشكل حازم مقاطع
كما قلت لا اعتقد انه سوف يتم الاستهداف
المواقع التي اطلقت منها الصواريخ ولكن
بشكل محدود لانه اولا تم وقف اطلاق
الصواريخ من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى لانه
لا توجد حتى هذه اللحظه جهه قد تبنت بشكل
واضح ما حدث هناك اليوم في اسرائيل عيد
الفصح وعيد الفصح هو
له قدسيه يوم السبت واغلب
الاحتياط
الدوله منقطعه عن وسائل الاتصال على الاقل
المتدينين في اسرائيل وبالتالي طبعا كان
هناك استغلال لهذا اليوم المساله ليست فقط
متعلقه باحداث المسجد الاقصى او البلده
القديمه التي شهدناها في الامس وقبل امس
ولكن خاصه ان هذا اليوم وبالتالي اعتقد
انه الكاسيون في الواقع توقعوا ان يكون
هناك
استغلال لهذا لهذا الظرف ولكن حزب الله
طبعا هو لا يتبني اي شيء هو ربما خائف
ربما منهمك في هذه الاخرى منهمك بقتل
الشعب السوري والعراقيين والتامر على شعب
اليمن لا اعتقد انه سوف يضحي بما كسب منذ
عام 2006 واصبحت الدوله اللبنانيه رهينه
في يده لن يغامر في الدخول في مواجهه
شامله
فلذلك انا اعتقد انه سوف تكون ضربات
محدوده ولن تؤدي الى المزيد من
التصيد
فقط نحن مستمرون في تغطيتنا لكن نشير ايضا
في جانب اخر الان الى هذه الصور التي
نشاهدها من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
في الزاويه الاخرى من الشاشه والزاويه
اليمنى من الشاشه
للتظاهرات واحتجاجات ومواجهات ايضا عنيف
مع قوات الامن الفرنسيه الان هذه
الاحتجاجات
مستمره في فرنسا على مشروع سلاح نظام
التقاعد
[تصفيق]
نتابع في تغطيتنا اليونيفران يقول ان
الوضع الراهن في جنوب لبنان خطير جدا
وندعو جميع الاطراف الى تجنب
التصعيد موقف
نتنياهو الدكتور ميل مصري الان بعد هذه
العمليه يعني البعض مثلا يقول بانه حزب
الله او ايران من خلال هذه العمليه تريد
ان تستفيد من حاله الضعف التي
يواجهها نتنياهو الان وربما نتنياهو
يستفيد ايضا من هذه العمليه ويوسع ربما
رده في في لبنان بشكل اكبر يعني للخروج من
هذه الازمه مثل مثل هذه مثل هذه التحليل
او التقييم كيف كيف تراه تقراه يعني
ولا اتفق الشق الاول واختلف مع الشقه
الثانيه الشق الاول انا اتفق تماما انه
صحيح ربما هناك تقييم خاطئ من قبل بعض
الاطراف من انه اسرائيل منقسمه وانه خاصه
ما تم الترويج له من ان هناك
انشقاقات داخل الجيش ولم تكن هناك انشاء
القائد كان هناك مجرد انه اضراب من قبل
بعض الضباط الاحتياط والعدد كان محدود
للغايه وحصلوا على موافقه من القضاء
العسكري والامور صارت في اثاره الشرعيه
ولكن لم تحدث انشقاقات كما روج له في بعض
في بعض القنوات او في من قبل بعض الاوساط
ولكنني اختال اختلف مع الشقه الثاني من
انه نتنياهو سوف يستغل وحتى يخرج من ازمته
سوف يدخل في حرب موسعه لا انا لا اعتقد
اولا هذا
لا ليس فيه هناك اجهزه امنيه في اسرائيل
هناك توصيات تاتي من الجيش هناك استخبارات
عسكريه وكذلك في كذلك انه في حاله في حاله
حرب
رئيس المعارضه كذلك دور هو يتم استشارته
وبالتالي السيد لقيت حاليا وبالتالي انا
اريد ان اقول انه لا علاقه بين اللون
السياسي الحكومه او ما تواجهه الح
كومه
الظرف الامني
ان شئنا وبالتالي انا اقول انه لا علاقه
بين بين هذا وذاك ليه علاقه بيننا لا احد
في اسرائيل يشكك في شرعيه الحكومه او في
نزاهه الانتخابات التي اتت بها الى الى
سدد الحكم ولكن
المعارضه هي معارضه لمشاريع قوانين لها
علاقه بالتعديلات القضائيه اوقف نتنياهو
قلت من وتيره المظاهرات انعاد نتنياهو مره
اخرى
واصر على مشروعيه سوف تعود مره اخرى
المظاهرات بالشكل الذي رايناه قبل اسبوع
وبالتالي الموضوع له علاقه له بالمسائل
الامنيه يعني لن يمرر مشاريع التعديلات
القضائيه في ظل حرب مع لبنان او حزب الله
لا لا لا لا لن يسمح له في اسرائيل لا
علاقه مره اخرى بين هذا ولكن ربما انه
الطرف الاخر يقيم الامور هكذا وكان هذا
صحيح اعتقد انه خطا
طيب اذا هل هناك يعني هل نجح ربما حزب
الله او ايران في مساله اختبار الخطوط
الحمراء الان على منطقه الحدود اللبنانيه
لاسرائيليه كما يرى البعض
قد انه هم يعرفون اسرائيل اكثر من اي طرف
اخر يعني لا اعتقد انهم بحاجه ان يختبروا
اسرائيل او او حكومه ثانيه ولكن هو ما
يحدث هو انه يجب من حين اخر ان يكون هناك
تكون هناك رده فعل لانه مصدر شرعيه وجود
حزبه طبعا شرعيه بين هلالين هو هو
المقاومه المقاومه لاسرائيل ولكن حزبه
عاجز تماما ان يفعل اي شيء ضد اسرائيل
لانه يخشى من ان تكون هناك مواجهه شامله
وبالتالي هو يبارك بعض او او يعطي ضوء
اخضر لبعض هذه الجماعات المسلحه
وربما كذلك يساعدها عسكريا بين هلالين من
خلال امدادها ببعض التقنيات او حتى ببعض
المواد ولكن ولكن
وخاصه وان اسرائيل خاصه فقصفت في الاسابيع
الفائته مواقع للحرس الثوري ومواقع الحزب
الله نفسه في في داخل السوري وبالتالي ان
تكون هناك رده فعل انا اعتقد انه
هذا شيء شيء هام للغايه بالنسبه لمحور
ايران ولكن التزم الام
ور انا لا اعتقد انه هذا هو كان المغزى ان
هناك رغبه من قبل من يوجه حزب الله لان
تدخل تدخل المنطقه
والجنوب اللبناني في في حرب في حرب جديده
مع اسرائيل على شاكله حرب 2006 الوضع
مختلف تماما واضافه الى ذلك هناك بعض
المواقع كثيره في جنوب لبنان ليست تحت
امره حزب الله كما ذكر من قبل ضيف وكذلك
هناك ترى فروسي تواجد لروسيا الوضع اختلف
تماما عن مكان عليه في في السابق انا لا
اعتقد اننا على عتاب حرب جديده بين
اسرائيل ولبنان انا استبعد ذلك تماما وفي
مسار العمليات التي تواجهها اسرائيل على
بعض يعني المناطق والمليشيات او عناصر
الحرس الثوري او بعض القواعد الموجوده في
سوريا يعني كما حدث في الايام الاخيره هل
ستتاثر بهذه العمليات
لا لا اخرى هناك خطوط واضحه
اسرائيل لا تستهدف اي عنصر لحزب الله مجرد
لاستهداف حزبه لا اسرائيل تستهدف اولا
الامداد
الى حزب الله من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى
التواجد الصاروخي الايراني على الاراضي
السوريه اذا هناك اهداف واضحه المعالم على
سبيل المثال لو بعد اسبوع
اكتشفت اسرائيل ان هناك
شاحنات تحمل الصواريخ الايرانيه او باخرها
او او طائره فسوف تستهدفها اسرائيل بمعزل
عما يحدث وبالتالي هناك اهداف واضحه
المعالم
لها علاقه اسرائيل لا تس
تهدف لانه حزب الله او ميليشيات ايران
لانها ميليشيات ايران ولكن لانها تريد ان
يكون هناك تواجد صاروخي ايراني على
الاراضي السوريه من ناحيه والا تصل اسلحه
استراتيجيه الى يد حزب الله هل سترد
اسرائيل على هذه العمليه كذلك في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه في غزه في غيرها من الاراضي
لا اعتقد لا اعتقد ان هناك علاقه عضويه
بين
قطاع غزه لان هناك مجموعات ربما قريبه من
حماس ولكن لا اعتقد ان هناك علاقه عضويه
بين هذا وذاك وكذلك اسرائيل لا مصلحه لها
بان يكون هناك تصعيد يعني من يرغب في
تصعيد ربما اطراف اخرى هي التي ترغب في
اشعال النيران لكن ليس هو هدف اسرائيل
وبالتالي اسرائيل لن تتحجج بما يحدث
لاستهداف مواقع في في قطاع غزه حسب
اعتقادي
الان كيف تنظر اسرائيل الى ما يحدث الان
يعني في
طبيعه التغيرات التي تمر بها المنطقه في
ضوء هذه العمليه دكتور ماي
اي نوع من التغيرات نتحدث نتحدث ربما عن
وساطه دخول صيني في المنطقه وساطه بين او
اتفاق ايراني كذلك سعودي اضافه الى
متغيرات اخرى متعلقه كذلك مثلا على سبيل
المثال ما يحدث الان من ضربات عسكريه من
الاسرائيليه في في سوريا اخر تواجد بارجه
عسكريه امريه امريكيه ايضا في سوريا في
الوضعيه القتاليه كل هذه المتغيرات الان
بالاضافه الى هذا الحدث الجديد كيف يمكن
قراءتهم في وجهه النظر الاسرائيلي
من ان هناك اختراق صيني او تواجد روسي قد
ازداد في الاونه الاخيره او تراجع امريكا
لا اعتقد انه كل هذا مبالغ فيه كثيرا لانه
نحن اذا ننظر الى اين هو التواجد الصيني
في الواقع ادي على ارض الواقع اين هو
التواجد الصيني بشكل اوسط هل هناك تواجد
عسكري الصيني هل هناك تواجد عسكري روسي
باستثناء مناطق نظام الاسد في في سوريا
وبالتالي لا يجب ان نبالغ في هذا كمان
العلاقات رائعه بين اسرائيل وروسيا بعكس
ما يروجه البعض وهناك تنسيق كامل بين
اسرائيل والجيش الروسي على الارض السوريه
وبعضنا عن ذلك العلاقات جيده بين اسرائيل
وروسيا تاريخيا وخاصه بعد تفكك الاتحاد
السوفيتي وبالتالي هناك مبالاه اما يتعلق
مساله
التقارب مع ايران اننا غدا اقول لك استاذي
الكريم ان هناك وجهه نظر تقول
ولكنني اعرضها لانني لا اتفق مع هذا ما
يقال بانه يعني انه هذا لا يصوب في مصلحه
اسرائيل التقارب اولا اعاده العلاقات على
مستوى السفارات بين الامارات العربيه
المتحده وايران ثم السعوديه وايران هناك
من يعتقد انه هذه مصر خطوره انا اعتقد انه
هذا لا يمس قالت لماذا لان هناك التوجه
يقول بانه حل المشاكل حل المشاكل يكون من
خلال الاشتباك ووجود علاقات وليس يكتفي
بهذا القدر لم يعد لدي المزيد من الوقت
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور ماهر المصري استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه القدس
تعطيها مستمر نذهب الى الزملاء في دبي
الزميله ميسون عزه معكم